JUSTIN BECKWITH: Welcome,
and thanks for coming.
Today we're going to talk about
running Node.js applications
on Google Cloud Platform.
We're going to take a look at
Google Cloud, build a few apps,
and learn about using Google's
advanced APIs and services
with your applications.
But before we dive in, a
little bit about myself.
My name is Justin Beckwith,
and I'm a product manager here
at Google.
My contact information
is available here,
so feel free to
reach out at any time
if you have questions or
feedback about running Node.js
applications on
Google Cloud Platform.
As someone who spent
years as a web developer,
I've found that there's a
lot to like about Node.js.
Many developers spend
years writing JavaScript
for fun and web applications.
One of the best parts of Node.js
is that it's just JavaScript.
The same skills you use
to develop applications
in the browser can be used to
develop amazing applications
in the cloud as well.
It's easy to get ramped
up, as the core of Node.js
is very small.
Many of the libraries are
going to use our open source
and have been
developed by community.
Last month, there were
over 4 billion packages
downloaded through NPM, the
Node.js package manager.
This is a sign of a
community that's growing.
As the Node.js community
continues to grow,
it's becoming a
great destination
for enterprise focused
web applications.
Node.js offers a mature API and
an LTS release schedule that
provides 18 months of support.
Over that same time,
Google Cloud Platform
has also grown and become
a great destination
for web applications and
APIs that need Google scale.
Node.js is built on V8,
the same JavaScript engine
that powers Google Chrome.
We have years of experience
tuning JavaScript engines
to provide incredible
performance in the browser.
And now we're helping
deliver that same incredible
performance in the cloud.
Google Cloud Platform
is also easy to use.
You can bring your
code and let us
handle the scale and the ops.
Finally, we offer a variety
of APIs and services
that allow you to take advantage
of Google's incredible big data
and machine learning technology.
The same infrastructure
in APIs that
make it possible to run services
like Google Search, Gmail,
and Google Photos are all
now at your fingertips,
helping you bring your
applications to life.
There are three easy ways
to run your applications
on Google Cloud.
App Engine is Google's
powerful, easy to use
platform as a service.
You bring your code and
we'll handle the rest.
App Engine will automatically
scale your application
to handle spikes in traffic,
provide no-downtime upgrades,
and make it easy
to take advantage
of our advanced diagnostics
tools and production.
Container Engine
is a hosted version
of Kubernetes, which
brings Google's container
orchestration
technology to the cloud.
It's incredibly powerful for
applications that are already
built on top of Docker.
And finally, if you
need complete control
and flexibility,
Compute Engine offers
traditional virtual
machines that you
can manage and control.
Now that we know a little bit
about Google Cloud and Node.js,
let's build a simple
web application
and deploy it to App Engine.
You can get started using any
Node.js framework you'd like,
but today we're
going to use Express,
a very common module used
for building web applications
and APIs.
I'm going to start by
scaffolding a new web
application using Express.
We're going to install our
dependencies locally and take
a quick look at
the app in action.
This is a simple application.
Now let's get it up and
running on App Engine.
To get started, you need
to create a new project
in the Google Cloud
developer console.
I'm going to deploy to a
project I created earlier
using the Google Cloud SDK.
The gcloud preview
app deploy command
will publish your code
to Google App Engine,
install any NPM dependencies
in your package.json,
and start your app.
Under the hood, we're
creating cloud load balancers,
virtual machines, auto scalers,
managed instance groups,
virtual networks,
everything you need
to build a great performing
application with a great SLA.
Now that our application
has been deployed,
let's check it out.
I'm going to run gcloud preview
app browse to take a look
at my site in production.
And here you have it, a
simple Node.js application
with Express running
on Google App Engine.
Now up to this point, we've
been using the Cloud SDK
to work on our app.
Let's take a look at how we can
use the Google Cloud developer
console to help manage it.
Here we can see the
App Engine dashboard,
which provides a heads-up view
of our application performance
metrics.
There's a lot to
explore with App Engine,
but some of the
most useful features
I want to talk about today
are under the Versions
tab in the developer console.
App Engine makes it easy
to simultaneously run
multiple versions
of your application.
This is useful in
a few situations.
First, it's great for performing
no-downtime deployments,
where you want to test a
new version of your app
before sending any users
to the new deployment.
You can see that I have a few
versions of this app already
deployed.
Here's the new version
we just deployed,
and the previous
version we were running.
This is a great feature if
you need high availability
and no-downtime upgrades.
In our case, we were
routing 100% of our traffic
to a new version.
But what if you want
to gradually roll out
your changes?
Or what if you want to
perform AB testing and route
different users to distinct
versions of your application?
Traffic splitting makes enabling
these kinds of setups simple.
As we saw, getting started
with Node.js on App Engine
is really easy.
You can bring your
code and let us run it
on Google's infrastructure.
You can automatically
scale to millions
of requests per second, and
you don't need to have downtime
during your deployments.
Now you may be wondering,
what if I decide
to use Container Engine, or
I want to move my application
on-premise?
Well, I've got great news.
The same Docker image we used
to run your application on App
Engine can be used
with Container Engine,
or Kubernetes, or any
other service that
can run Docker containers.
Our last application
was really simple.
It was just a single
web application
with no real backend.
In reality, our apps
are rarely this simple.
They're often more complex,
because the problems
we're trying to solve for our
customers are also complex.
We need databases like
MongoDB, Postgres, or Datastore
to store our content.
We need message queues
for connecting services.
We need advanced services, like
the Cloud Vision API and Cloud
ML to help us understand
the world around us.
We use advanced tools like
BigQuery and Data Flow
to process millions of records
to gain valuable insights
on our products.
On Google Cloud Platform,
you can combine all of these.
Google products,
open source products,
managed services,
bring your own,
use what you want to
build the experiences
that your customers need.
When you're ready to take
advantage of Google's APIs
and services, you can use
the gcloud NPM module.
This NPM module gives you
access to over a dozen Google
APIs and services,
with more on the way.
It works from within App Engine,
Kubernetes, Compute Engine,
even from applications that
aren't deployed to Google Cloud
Platform.
In my experience,
these are the services
that make Google magic.
Containers, the
Cloud Vision API,
BigQuery, Machine Learning.
We can use these
amazing technologies
to build applications that
serve billions of people
all over the planet.
Let's take a look at how you
can use these to get started.
Next, we're going to take a
look at a fun little Node.js
application that uses
the gcloud NPM module.
This app uses App Engine, Cloud
Storage, the Cloud Vision API,
and Cloud Pub/Sub to analyze
images from the internet,
separate them into pictures
of dogs on the right,
and cats on the left.
So now let's take
a look at how we
can use these APIs with
the gcloud NPM module
to build this kind
of application.
To store our images, we're
using Google Cloud Storage.
Cloud storage provides
a scalable file store,
great for images, videos, or
other large files that you want
to keep out of your database.
Using the Cloud
Storage API is simple.
You can even use it to
serve static HTTP content.
Next up is the Cloud Vision API.
Using this simple service,
with five lines of code,
we can detect common
labels, landmarks,
and even facial
expressions within an image
almost instantaneously.
Finally, we're
using Cloud Pub/Sub
to send messages between
the microservices that
make up this application.
Cloud Pub/Sub provides low
latency durable messaging
between services or devices.
Using these APIs, we can
take advantage of technology
that's been in development
at Google for years.
Whether it's our machine
learning technology, databases,
or big data tools,
we have services
that make building amazing
applications fast and scalable.
Of course, sometimes you're
going to run into trouble.
We've all been in
a situation where
code works great
on our machines,
but for one reason or
another, starts giving us
trouble in production.
Traditionally, debugging
these kinds of problems
has been very difficult.
But with the Stackdriver
diagnostics tools,
we can dig deep
into performance and quality
issues in production.
Let's take a look at
Stackdriver Trace in action.
In the developer
console, I'm going
to navigate to the Trace UI.
This will show an overview
of the overall latency
for requests to
my HTTP endpoints.
I'm going to drill into
the Traces view, which
provides a detailed breakdown
of every single outgoing HTTP
and RPC call coming from my app.
As you can see, this last
request took around 10 seconds.
That's a long time.
Let's find out why.
I can see that we're
downloading a lot of images
to run through the
Cloud Vision API.
You can see every
request we're making
to download images, upload
them to cloud storage,
and analyze them with
the Cloud Vision API.
You can even click on a request
to get a drill-down view that
shows the origin of the request
in your application source
code.
This is a great way to
diagnose performance issues
in production.
But what if instead
of a performance issue
you're facing a crash?
Stackdriver Debugger
makes it easy to analyze
the state of your
application in production.
The debug console allows
you to set breakpoints
in your production code.
Now, this isn't a
traditional breakpoint.
When a request hits
this code path,
it will analyze the
state of your application
passively, allowing you to
capture state without affecting
performance in production.
In review, Stackdriver
diagnostic tools
make it easy to diagnose
issues in production.
We looked at Trace
and Debug, but there
are a variety of other tools
at your disposal as well.
Today we covered a lot.
We looked at how
App Engine is making
it easy to operate
at Google Scale.
We looked at using
Google's APIs and services
to build amazing applications.
We diagnosed problems
in production,
and of course, we talked about
how Google Cloud and Node.js
are a great match.
Everything we looked at
today is open source.
The Docker images we
used to build the Node.js
runtime, the gcloud NPM module,
the Trace and Debug tools,
these are all open source
and available on GitHub.
I'd like to thank
you again for coming.
And as I mentioned, please
feel free to reach out
if you have any questions.
You can learn more about
building Node.js applications
on Google Cloud Platform
at cloud.google.com/nodejs.